Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and yesterday
I asked you all to submit questions for a
new Game of Thrones related Q&A. I meant to
do Q&As every week but I got so many requests
for Teen Wolf videos this summer monday nights
it turned my schedule into a nightmare.
In the next two weeks I’m moving to a new
apartment and quitting my job to be a youtube
weirdo full time so it’s going to be crazy
for a little while longer but then you’ll
start seeing more Q&As and bonus videos for
everything.
If you’re just finding me and have no idea
what the hell I’m talking about. I do weekly
game of thrones videos and a weekly song of
ice and fire book giveaway, be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
George RR Martin just went to the Edinburgh
book festival and there was supposed to be
a livestream. I haven’t found a video link
but if he says anything interesting about
Winds of Winter I’ll include it in a bonus
video.
Let’s answer some questions! Most of these
I picked are Sand Snake and Season 5 related.
Starting with Number 1 - Jon Targaryen asks
will you please do a Winds of Winter Predictions
Video?
I always love trying to figure things out.
The reason I don’t do videos like this all
the time is because as of the end of last
year George RR Martin’s total book sales
were only about 28 Million. That’s a lot
of Song of Ice and Fire fans.
But most of the people who subscribe to me
only watch the show, or they just got started
with the books. During Season 4 the show averaged
10 Million viewers per an episode.
So as a compromise I only do big prediction
videos every once and a while. Even for the
show.
Martin withdrew from writing anything for
the show to focus on winds of winter. In my
fantasy he finishes the book in time for the
Season 5 finale in June 2015. November 2015
at the latest. So I’ll start doing more
book specific videos when that gets closer.
I don’t have an exact idea for when, but
I usually use twitter and facebook to poll
for interest in video topics so you can always
follow me there if you’re not already. Links
at the bottom of the description.
moving on Question number 2 - Alek Kanwischer
(no avatar) asks do you have a favorite character
you want to see on the Iron Throne?
I don’t think I’ve said this before, but
in the last year I’ve actually stopped thinking
of the Iron Throne as a desirable thing.
Think about it this way. The crown is hopelessly
in debt, everyone at court is a liar or a
thief. And the really interesting people have
been scattered to the four winds.
I think the real goal should be to restore
the supernatural balance. There are maybe
a handful of characters in the books that
have their minds on that. The rest are all
focused on the here and now. Either gaining
control of a city or a single kingdom in the
case of Westeros.
The Iron Throne is just a symbol, Robert Baratheon
won the throne and it ended up killing him.
If you’re someone like Bronn then you really
don’t care about anything except having
sex with your new wife Lollys in your new
castle. I tend to think more like Maester
Aemon. He has a much broader perspective on
what’s happening in the world just because
he’s seen so much history.
I actually have a lot of spoilery thoughts
about maester aemon that I’ll write in the
comments for anyone that wants to read them.
On to Question 3 - Edvuxas112 asks do you
think they’ll show a big non-book scene
like the white walker in episode 4?
You’re asking if the show will do something
from the books that was happening but George
RR Martin didn’t write it in a POV chapter.
Definitely yes, they said they’re going
even further off book for a number of reasons.
Which means there’s an even better chance
they’ll include something they think is
really important regardless of whether or
not George RR Martin chose to include it.
I think a good example would be showing us
the creation of Robert Strong. In the books
it’s just implied who he is and where he
came from. Qyburns lab underneath the black
cells. Or they’ll show us more of Qyburn’s
black magic. Or what the other characters
think is black magic.
He’s kind of like the doctor frankenstein
of the series, blending the knowledge of the
maesters with necromancy and other magic.
I’m also hoping to learn more about him
in Winds of Winter.
Speaking of which, I also think more of these
non-book scenes from the Lands of Always winter
will happen, but not a lot. I don’t think
they’d go a whole year without showing a
big white walker scene.
Question 4 - Josephine Swift asks what do
you think they’ll do with the Ironborn characters?
I think the show is going to narrow it’s
focus to characters it’s already spent most
of it’s time on, Theon for all intents and
purposes is the ironborn storyline even though
last season Yara said he wasn’t her brother
anymore just because he had been consumed
by the Reek persona.
Ironborn are completely gone but I think they’ll
take all the big victarion and euron moments,
pick the most essential parts and give them
to her. It’s like when cut out Edric Storm
and gave his story to Gendry.
I think that’s what they’ll do with the
Uncles. I know everyone really wants to see
them but unless they cast them by October
or November, they won’t make it into season
5. And at that point it would be cheaper and
easier for them to just send Yara to the place
where Euron goes in Book 5. That’s really
when his story starts to get interesting.
They could truncate the kingsmoot and just
give all of that plot to her from then on
out.
I’ll still do a video for the Greyjoy Uncles
at some point. But when I do I’ll make sure
to say what I think the show will change specifically
about their plot.
Question 5 - Nick Falba (no avatar) asks,
what do you think they’ll do with the Dornish
master plan given that a lot of the involved
characters haven’t been cast?
If anyone hasn’t heard about the Dornish
master plan, it’s a plan that Oberyn Martell
and Prince Doran concocted after Elia was
killed to get revenge on the Lannisters. I
think the best way I can explain it without
going into crazy spoilers is that I think
the show will just simplify everything.
It seems like they cut out Arianne, who’s
role inside the master plan had already been
changed because of character deaths. And Quentyn,
the backup, was also not cast. So they’ll
probably just cut out the whole marriage part
of the plan with those two characters. And
promise Trystane to the person Quentyn was
trying to marry.
I said it in my Sand Snakes video but I’m
pretty sure based on the recast that they’ll
spend more time on the Myrcella plot. It’s
technically not part of the Master Plan, Myrcella
was part of Arianne’s side plot. I think
the show will just add Myrcella to their version
of the Master Plan.
Sorry if that sounds confusing. Right now
Trystane is betrothed to Myrcella, that won’t
change. But they’ll probably tease the Quentyn
plot behind the Lannister’s backs. I don’t
think they’ll send Trystane on the trip
Quentyn took though. I think they’ll just
tease it in a letter they send.
I’ll clarify even more in the comments for
people that need it.
But moving on Question 6 - Flying Spectacles
says, once they’re done with the show, they
should do other big historical events like
Robert’s rebellion, the andal invasion etcetera.
Yes, all good suggestions, you listed a bunch
of the big historical events. Game of Thrones
is a huge deal at HBO, this year it became
their most watched series of all time. Meaning
it’s making them more money than anything
next to their sporting events. Or driving
subscriptions. They don’t advertise, so
profits are measured in premium subscribers.
This is the same deal at AMC with Walking
Dead, that show is so profitable that AMC
is going to bend time and space to keep Walking
Dead content on their network till the end
of time. Just because it’s guaranteed profits.
They already signed a development deal with
George RR Martin during season 1 for a spin
off show. There haven’t been any announcements
about it since then, but as long as Martin
gives HBO the rights to future content, they’ll
keep doing it. Either as tv series or miniseries
or tv movies.
Do not worry, there will be some form of Game
of Thrones content for at least the next 4
years, after that I can’t say. Just because
HBO hasn’t made any official comments about
stuff after the main series.
Question 7 - Albert A asks, do you think they’re
going to take out Jaime’s Story in Book
4 or do it later?
If you watched the spoilery part of my video
yesterday I said that he and Bronn will go
somewhere different. So they’ll probably
just cut out the Riverrun stuff completely.
The King’s Landing stuff that he’s involved
in will probably stay the same.
Question 8 - Capn Jack asks was the picture
of Bradley James a coincidence or did my spoiler
casting dreams just come true?
That was just me using a picture for a person
I thought resembled Harry Hardyng. He’s
not on the show and they haven’t cast that
character. There’s a billion characters
in a song of ice and fire, but there’s not
pictures for a lot of them. So when you talk
about someone that there’s no media for
you have to get creative.
If I were a halfway decent artist I’d make
my own fan drawing for people when I talk
about them.
I suppose there’s always a chance Brad James
could make it on the show. But usually game
of thrones casts lesser known actors. Jonathan
Pryce is the exception this season because
he’s a really big actor. It gives you an
idea for how much weight they’re going to
place on the High Sparrow character.
Question 9 - bh061709 asks with the death
of JJ Murphy what do you think they’ll do
at the wall?
For anyone that didn’t hear an actor playing
a night’s watch character just died in real
life.
JJ Murphy was playing Denys Mallister. He
was going to be the biggest candidate to succeed
Jeor Mormont as the next Lord Commander. The
producers said they’re not going to recast
the role. They had only filmed for 4 days
so he still had scenes left to finish.
They’ll probably just write around it and
speed up the transition to the new Lord Commander.
If you’ve read the books just use spoiler
tags when commenting about it.
and last question number 10 - The Jeebz Machine
says, Charlie never replies to me and it makes
me sad…
I’m sorry you feel that way but your comment
gives me a good opportunity to mention some
youtube specific things. You do not have replies
turned on, so even if I wanted to reply to
you, I could not. If you look at your comment
here it means no one can reply to you, otherwise
the reply button would appear like Greenmailerr
here below you.
So big request from me to all of you guys,
if you have not already, please make sure
replies are turned on. If you haven’t, bind
your channel to a google plus account, otherwise
comments won’t work and no one will ever
be able to reply to you.
Also really big thing, make sure to upload
an avatar. I think half the people’s questions
I picked in this video have no avatar. I love
to show off your faces in my videos when you
leave comments I really like. But I can’t
do that if you have no avatar.
So make sure replies are turned on for your
comments so we can all talk to each other
and make sure to upload an avatar so we can
all see each other’s beautiful faces.
Avatars are now controlled on google plus.
So you upload it there and it will automatically
appear on your youtube channel.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting questions
and once I move into my new apartment in a
couple weeks I will do a room tour. It will
just give me the opportunity to make all of
this look a little bit nicer and I’ll have
more time to make videos and comment on comments.
My next bonus video like I said yesterday
will be faceless men. But real quick the winner
of this week’s book giveaway is Time Vampire
83. Congrats, you get your pick of an of martin’s
books or short stories. Paperback or kindle.
I’ll message you on your channel for details.
There was a new Doctor Who Trailer so video
for that coming tomorrow, but in the meantime
if you haven’t seen it learn about all 8
of the sand snakes here and click here to
learn about the big season 5 changes they’re
making to the books.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!